hello everyone I'm Brenda mone yep and
I'm the director of programs here at the
Museum and I'm happy to welcome you to
the museum this evening I'm also quite
pleased to have Iran egusi and Jason
Levine here I'm sure you're all eager as
well for a wonderful conversation and
performance this evening
Iran has probably been thinking about
bringing Jason to MIT for a long time
but it was about a year ago when he and
I talked about how we might bring Jason
in front of the public to have a
conversation about what he does and why
and how and from that conversation
developed tonight's program as well as a
coding workshop that Jason is going to
lead on Thursday here at the Museum I
think there are a couple of spots left
for that workshop so if you're
interested in joining us
please look online the same place where
you got your ticket for this this
program tonight so without further ado
I'd like to introduce Iran egusi who is
professor of the practice of music
technology at MIT and you might know him
better as co-founder of harmonics thanks
Brenda
hey everyone thanks for coming I'm
really excited today to be introducing
Jason to come talk to you all and
perform for you all and then after that
he and I will have a little discussion
here and try to get you guys involved as
well it's really awesome to see students
of my class raise your hand students hey
awesome
it's Jason is actually here for the
whole week and it's part of a residence
that we're having so he's giving this
talk tonight plus the workshop on
Thursday that Brenda talked about but
he's also going to be lecturing in my
class tomorrow for my class interactive
music systems and we'll be talking to
students about their final projects and
giving them some advice about that so
we're really looking forward to him
working with us in that capacity I met
Jason God we were talking about this I
think it was 2011
it was when I was still working at
harmonics and the Kinect had just come
out and there was a conference down at
Carnegie Mellon called the art and code
conference and they were particularly
looking at ways to use code to make cool
art using the Kinect so I went down
there as as well as someone I see here
from from Harmonix as well
Mike Mandel and Jason was doing this
crazy performance where he was on stage
with a screen behind him and the Kinect
was doing a 3d capture of his of his
position in his body and that was being
rendered onto the screen but using
waveforms and it also turns out he's
like one of the world's top beatboxing
artists so he was like beatboxing and
doing this this kind of hard to describe
show and since then he's just done more
and more interesting things and he'll
talk about all of those today so I won't
bore you with more introductions other
to say that again I'm really excited to
have Jason here Jason come on up
[Applause]
hello hello
so my name is Jason as you know and I'm
a computational artist and musician and
based in New York but I grew up in
Montreal so I really appreciate the
summer weather you guys are having right
now so I've been interested in music and
computers for as long as I can remember
and my parents took notice of my
interest in computers and so they went
to a garage sale and picked up a used
computer so this was my first computer
was the IBM PC jr. had 128 kilobytes of
RAM and 4.7 megahertz CPU and no hard
drive so if you have no hard drive or
any drive at all what happens when you
start up a computer well I would just
get this screen I didn't know what to do
with it but lucky for me that it came
with a manual so I taught myself basic
by writing these sort of choose your own
adventure style text adventures so
something like you see a door opened or
you enter a room with a lamp in it turn
on land you see a dresser with a drawer
open drawer there's a box in the drawer
and on and on so I would kind of I would
spend all day trying to build these text
adventures but then every night my
father would come down and because in
these times there was no sleep mode or
really even screen savers computer I had
to be turned off and since they had no
hard drive everything was erased so I
had this zen-like practice of trying to
take the text adventure to the next
level each day until all my work was
erased and my father was talking with
some friends of my plight and so one of
his friends gave him a five and a
quarter disk entitled dos 1.1 so I
didn't get the manual but I was allowed
to use it once in a while so I still
then have a hard drive but I just
basically left this drive in my computer
all the time
and there's no games or much to do so I
just learned how to do batch files and
my one my one sort of achievement was
there was a I edited the binary of the
system kernel by hand I replaced all
instances of Exe with fu N and I swear
to god it worked
executable files would not run until you
renamed them thought if he went I'm sure
you can't do that anymore
but back yeah you know I had a lot of
time so I was looking clearly looking
for fun in computers and I found it
at elementary school where they taught
logo writer so for those of you not
familiar logo writer was a programming
language aimed for educators and you had
this little turtle and you could say you
could draw a line by saying go forward
10 pixels turn right 90 degrees and make
all sorts of abstract geometry but it
was advanced enough you could also make
some animations or even a game so it
turned out I really liked it and the
moment I don't remember most of this
because obviously it was 1992 but at the
moment I do remember was when the three
of us were put in a room and we were
given five problems and we had to pick
which three we were gonna solve in this
limited amount of time and then we went
to solving them and I think it was my
first experience of the sort of liveness
that can happen in programming so around
the same time or maybe a bit earlier
another friend of my parents invited me
to perform with the emus II to the
mobile chamber orchestra doing a
Mozart's music for children and I had
the cuckoo which is the one hold flute
and I had one job and that was when the
two remember the time when the orchestra
stops and then I go to 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2
but the story was they never knew when I
was going to come in and every time I
invented some new rhythm and they had to
be on their toes to know when was the
right time to
back in so basically by age 11 I already
had a taste for live news encoding
hacking you know system critical files
without making a backup and wild and
unruly musical improvisation and now 25
years later I'm taller so I did learn
spreadsheets and databases and
touch-typing and C in high school but
really most of my energy was focused on
this new high energy I see you guys are
all like who are those bands is hi this
kind of high energy rock music that was
coming out and I liked it so much that
when I finished high school I started a
band with some friends and ended up
dropping out of science and going to
music school I was never much of a bass
player but one thing that I really loved
was all the pedals the delays the
distortions the reverbs the flames the
phasers these little boxes with knobs
that you could just control and shape
the sound but unlike my guitars friends
at the time who were collecting the
little boss pedals I went on a
little-known site called eBay and got a
programmable multi-effects pedal so the
signal chain was fixed but you could
change which effects were on and the
parameters it was very awkward to
programs he had these little buttons to
chain to move around and change stuff
but my my best friend Diego realized
that you could push the delay to three
and a half seconds and you could set it
so when you push the the foot pedal up
it set the feedback of the delay loop to
a hundred percent making it into a loop
pedal now I noted a live looping is you
know practically a musical genre of its
own and there's plenty of dedicated
hardware but back in 2000 2001 there was
like nothing maybe just one rackmount
unit from TC Helicon that costs you know
a couple grand
so Diego got one of these pedals and we
started a group called tabula rasa and I
played all sorts of percussion and
guitar and beatboxing and throw
singing and he played bass flute and
singing but the truth was we are really
playing the peddles
so we had these just these
choreographies where we would change
effects at the same time to create these
song structures and polyrhythmic effects
but i felt like i needed even more sort
of programmatic control so we got this
26 channel 26 channel mixer and
connected everything we possibly could
to it and set it up so you could send
any signal anywhere and even send the
pedals to each other and create these
wild feedback effects so we did that for
a couple years but ultimately it was too
complicated and unwieldy to perform with
life and so we created a more
stripped-down live back after music
school I went to do computer science but
again I spent more time beatboxing then
actually going to school I beatboxing in
bars and clubs and weird circus
festivals in the forest and then I would
put on a shirt and beatbox in a
wholesome a cappella group but I just
couldn't get down with the way computer
science was taught there wasn't much
coding to be honest and it was just very
dry and static and theoretical until in
halfway through my degree I found out
that I could do a minor in music
technology and this is where I learned
about physical computing and especially
max/msp so this was just an absolute
game changer it solved uhm wait you guys
have raise of hands heard of that
max/msp yeah I'm assuming that's what I
thought
this is just a game changer coming from
the kind of hardware system with this
mess of cables because now I could set
up my signal chain however I wanted I
could have as many delays as I want
loops as long as I wanted but even more
than that there was this notion of
interactivity that you could take a
sensor to control parameters or my
favorite was using a signal of a
performer to actually affect their own
signal an example of that
this is a performance so whenever the
singer holds a note for three seconds it
captures the eight loudest harmonics in
her voice and tune some resonant filters
which I'm then beatboxing but as much as
I love music technology I thought so
burnt out from the computer science
degree that in the end I decided you
know what I think I'm gonna follow the
path of performance and I literally ran
away and joined the circus
so I played most notably and I was the
beatboxer emcee in a kung-fu themed
Street circus group but I also battled
flamenco dancers accompany DJs and this
picture in the corner here that's not
even a circus group
those are my roommates at the time and
so I literally thought this would be my
life I travel the world just beatboxing
and repeating you know silly comedy
lives but then one by one all my circus
collaborators started studying
contemporary dance and I remember when a
close my closest collaborator man UCF
asked me to vocally a company and be the
soundtrack for his first choreography
and we were in this acoustically dry
room and I was trying to do my sort of
explosive sound effects but he was doing
all these subtle and bizarre movements
and it just didn't work so I knew
exactly what I had to do I dug up some
old max patches and I created a system
with this very long delay that was
slowly increasing in feedback so that it
began with very one-to-one sound effects
slowly became a kind of layered
soundscape so I continued to to work
with the circus groups but also start
incorporating more of these interactive
audio systems into the work with
performers but what I started to feel
was that these complex and subtle
interactions and sounds needed to be
visualized I did a little bit of work
visualizing with max/msp but then
someone told me about something called
open frameworks I see a smile over here
so open frameworks when I first heard of
open frameworks I said oh man I haven't
done C++ in like five years since I
finished my degree I don't know if I
remembered anymore but it only took me
one time to know that this would be my
tool of choice because unlike the black
boxes of max/msp I could have direct
manipulation of data at the lowest
levels and and just have like
high-performance graphics and an easy
interface to work with all sorts of
media from video to images to graphics
to sound and so I started making visuals
with open frameworks but then again I
felt like I wish there was a way that
the visuals could be aware of the
physical performers so I started doing
some research into IR sensors and I
dreamt up this whole system it was gonna
cost me one or two grand
and it would've been super complicated
to set up and hard to use and you've
probably guessed the punchline because
around then Microsoft released the the
xbox for Kinect sorry connect first box
and about as soon as it was released
Adafruit put a bounty on it for a couple
grand whoever could hack the drivers so
within one month there was full support
for the Kinect and open frameworks so I
set to creating interactive video pieces
with dancers so this is a piece with
video feedback and the angle and scale
of the the projection is controlled by
where the dancer is this is tracking the
vectors of the movement of the dancer
and then this one it's it's a particle
system reacting to the dancers movements
but you can't see or maybe can't see is
that these are all letters and there's
the letters of a poem and the piece
begins with with him reciting the poem
and as he starts to move away the
letters all start to follow them like
alphabet soup and the way we created
this piece was I had a sort of basic
particle system and then he would dance
with it and then give me suggestions can
can it start from this and these letters
leave first maybe it moves along this
type of curve and so every time he'd
give me a suggestion I would quit the
system and then I start typing like mad
and try and turn the idea into reality
start up the app again and then we'd
iterate in that way and so what I didn't
know about live coding at the time but
that's what I was trying to do the only
problem was that I had to quit the app
and so then the dancer couldn't interact
with the system while I was making
changes to it so I refined the technique
and this is with a dance company in New
York called Eric Taylor dance
and this led to me working with the
legendary Miss Lauren Hill I got to do
audio reactive visuals for her and it
was great because the entire band
I got an audio signal from every member
of the band and then I could choose
which visuals and what part of the
projection were reacting to her voice or
the drums or guitar solo
[Music]
[Music]
so just one geeky aside free if there's
any signal enthusiasts out there Lauren
Hill's voice is a really incredible
signal just it's just different you know
legendary but let's go back in time the
first piece I actually created when I
first got the connect and openFrameworks
working together was a solo piece that
was a synthesis of my work in physical
theater and dance and beatboxing and
interactive video and that was called
body open and this is the piece that
Iran was mentioning
[Music]
[Music]
and back in the day when I've seen this
video of people it was impossible to
convince them that there was no
post-processing
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so I got to take the the performance on
the tour and the first stop was art and
code 3d which was the Kinect hacking
conference put on by Golan Levin in the
studio for creative inquiry at Carnegie
Mellon and something amazing happened
during my performance there and well not
amazing but that is that the code
crashed and it crashed right in the
middle so infinity crashed at the
beginning I would have asked the
audience can I start again and if it had
crashed near the end I would have just
pretended that that's where it was
supposed to end but it crashed right in
the middle and it actually crashed at a
point where the visuals go dark and it's
just ambient right before the build-up
to the final climax so I just jumped off
stage I forced quit the app and I just
started debugging in front of the whole
audience so I commented out some code
here I changed him
numbers there was a mad dash I wasn't
sure if it was gonna work hit compile
and we all watched as the rainbow beach
ball went and compiled and I jumped up
on stage now that's now full of
adrenaline and I finished the show and
the amazing part was multiple times
throughout the weekend of that
conference people came up to me and they
were like hey man your show was pretty
cool but that part where it crashed and
then you debugged it and then it worked
that made my weekend I was like really
and I was so curious but it's sort of
planted the seed that oh it can
programming via performance practice
anyway when I first got off stage this
unassuming guy came up to me and he said
hey you probably wouldn't be interested
but I have a video game company now
maybe we could work together he gave me
a card and it said Iran a go Z CTO of
harmonics so the next stop on the tour
was harmonics where I got to play for
the entire company during their lunch
hour which is a really interesting
experience then I went to Columbia to
play the international
image festival to India to the carnival
for each creativity and then finally to
Norway for the pixel festival which is a
really interesting open source software
art sort of conference festival and at
peak cell there was all these amazing
and very strange performances all with
Linux and one of them was this guy
writing code in an Emacs buffer and
creating these groovy beats and after
show I said hey man what was that that
was incredible and he said oh it's just
a haskell library i wrote and then
walked away i guess he was in a rush
because i didn't even catch his name but
that was that was Alex mcclain who was a
pioneer in the live coding movement and
the creator of tidal cycles which is
used a lot at what are called alga raves
where people dance to algorithmically
created music after the tour I went to
Harmonix
to work on this incredible project
called Fantasia music evolved which was
to take the classic 1940s Disney movie
Fantasia and make it an interactive game
where you could manipulate music and so
the they hired me to come in and I
couldn't believe it they said we want
you to just make cool things where you
manipulate music using the Kinect and
there's cool visuals are you serious
okay so here's a little example of the
game
now if you haven't tried the game you
should try it it's extremely expensive
I can't possibly show
[Music]
so this was one of the things that I
contributed to the games where the user
can manipulate the sort of walk base in
a sound or some other by as if it were
sort of a late
I was pretty abstract and one memory I
have at harmonic so I worked I did about
three contracts with harmonics and at
the end of one of the modern roof was
the first to the second but I sort of
got this vibe like I needed to make like
another good idea if I was going to get
another contract and so I I just started
hustling and I ended up making five
different interactive prototypes in five
days I remember on the Friday Iran and
the other execs came in and they kind of
looked at my stuff they said oh that's
cool you know that doesn't work maybe it
just could work with that and then after
they left Iran said good work man I like
this one prototype of day thing
oh no no I said this president but then
I thought about it and I was like no
this is sort of the most amazing thing
that I love about this medium that you
can have an idea for an interactive
audio-visual system and create it in a
day and that people can interact with it
by moving their hands in the air and
that is sort of the magic that I've been
after throughout my career so I got to
work creating interactive gestural
control instruments again this recently
with a company called the way VR it's a
social VR world where people go to
concerts together so this is from the
point of view of the person who's in VR
and there remix ting oh I should say
this is a la producer toki monsta
first-ever album released in vr so the
team took her album art and turned it
into entire world that people could
explore this is remix in drum samples
from the album and now this one each
lobe represents one of the stems for the
track so the users holding the drum and
then these are different filters that
they can put into
[Music]
and the keys track
[Music]
[Applause]
so VR in a way is a successor to the
Kinect in that it's this incredibly
precise way to do gestural control of
course you got to hold things in your
hand and wear goggles on your face but
so this was this is actually five years
about five years after harmonics but
right after harmonics I was accepted
into the school for a poetic computation
which is a you know someone know which
is a project of taehyun choi and zack
lieberman and many others and so this
was the first class in in 2013 it was a
really incredible program it was just
this sort of deprogramming kind of
education where you jumped from topic to
topic sometimes the students taught the
teachers the class content changed
within one lesson and one the first
assignment Zack ever gave was really
amazing because he said find a
programming language you've never heard
of or never at least never used and just
do something with it anything and so I
kind of went down this rabbit hole of
trying all these new languages and
that's where I found out about live
coding now I had heard some live coding
this sort of blips and noise and sort of
complex rhythmic stuff but this this was
totally different this is some code from
a language called impromptu created by
Andrew Sorensen and this is called a
study in Keith and it's inspired by the
jazz pianist Keith Jarrett and the first
two minutes are silent while he sets up
the base algorithms for the structure of
the piece and I love this because it's
kind of got like a John Cage feel but
it's functional
but I'll skip ahead here
where I sound oh yeah oops
so this is so different from what you
think of when you think of algorithmic
music and if you look over right over
here what he's typing this is like a
super minimal Markov chain right so
Markov chain is usually kind of like
seen as a black box and you feed it tons
of data and then you use it to predict
the next term based on the last couple
terms but here he's writing it from
scratch and then adding in to create
chord progressions and so I love this
idea of sort of immediate programming
and it's almost artisanal you know and
the data and the code is is together
[Music]
so this this really was the moment for
me when I realized that coding would be
my performance practice because before
when I thought I was bringing when I was
bringing code and performance together
really I would spend like a couple weeks
head down creating an interactive system
and then I spent a couple weeks
practicing with the system so it was
still separated in time and there's a
great paper called programming in time
by Andrew Sorensen and Henry Gardner
talking about how traditionally
programming has been split into the sort
of a problem to be solved its
implementation and then a product to be
used in the future and this software
software development ideology has just
how everyone thinks about programming
but it's nothing to do with the hardware
it doesn't have to be this way and so he
sort of talked about this more ephemeral
ephemeral kind of programming where it's
direct agency and so you're you have
ideas you turn them into code and in the
moment you start changing the sound
waves or the photons in the room and so
I started to look for like-minded Souls
and it turns out it's a very spread out
international community there's a little
hub in England in Mexico City and
Australia but not too many people in New
York so I ended up we started a group
with just four of us so there's Katie
Keogh who live codes dancers such as
sort of following in the Merce
Cunningham games of chance sort of idea
where she's algorithmically creating
choreographies that the dancers are
reacting to in real time
then there's Ramsay Nasir who's created
his own system for live coding
video games so whilst someone's playing
the game he can change the mechanics of
the game and then there's a Tom Murphy
and myself who live for traditional live
coders live coding dance music and such
and so we're now about ten core members
over 80 total members and we've put on
about fifteen algorithm's and two live
coding festivals and we'd love to do one
here so so I want to talk about how
different it is as a performer to as a
musician to live code then then just
when you're a human musician and so as a
musician you're always sort of in the
moment you've got this muscle memory
your body is the instrument and you have
all these you know internalized ideas of
musical structures and and culture and
so you're living in the moments you know
you have a little bit of the past and a
little bit of what could happen in the
future and be very fast and you know
emotional but when you're live coding
the process is completely different
you're in your computer you hear the
music you think of how you want to
change it and then you imagine how to
turn that into an algorithm and then how
to type that in code fast enough so that
when you evaluate the change it makes
musical sense and if you listen to a lot
of live coding music and you have a
musical background you'll notice that
most of it doesn't follow kind of normal
the norms of musical structure at all
and that's why but I really wanted to
create something musical and so I formed
a duo with singer-songwriter Mei Chung
and she has a background in jazz and
she's a strong improviser and what I
realized was when I'm thinking about
what to do while I'm thinking how to
turn into an algorithm on typing I still
hear her voice
I say in the corner of my ear and her
phrasing guides me to know when to make
a change to the music when to go
halftime when to change the key and so
here's a an example of some of the music
we make
[Music]
[Music]
people are confused
[Music]
and we just have these moments where we
change at the same time yeah and we've
been lucky to play all over New York LA
touring in Mexico and Hong Kong and just
being greeted with appreciation for this
strange sort of improvisational
electronic music that we do
people wear sunglasses to our shows I
don't know
[Music]
[Music]
so I want to take the next a little bit
to explain my process and how I've come
to the audiovisual system that I'm going
to be presenting you this evening so
just give you an idea of kind of the
basic way you make rhythms in live
coding is it's a succession of repeated
conditionals so you might say every
fourth beat play a kick drum and then on
the third beat of every four beats to a
snare drum play two high hats every beat
so that's kind of very direct and
one-to-one but I wanted to find a way to
go one level higher and sort of get more
emergent rhythms so what I started doing
was putting low frequency oscillators
sort of sine waves and such and sampling
them to choose from a list of drums so
here's a simple example with just three
drums you see as I change the frequency
of the drum you get some interesting
rhythm
so I started to push this and I had you
know ten drums that I sorted by hand
from lowest to highest pitch twenty
thirty but I wanted more I wanted like a
hundred or a thousand drums and I knew I
couldn't have them all in one line so I
had to find a way to have more
dimensions and while I was right around
the time when I was trying to figure out
this problem this image turned up on the
internet circulating reddit with the
tagline a computer made this art by
itself
spoiler alert computer din make that art
it was the deep mind group at Google and
this came out of some research to try
and figure out how the state of the art
neural networks for image object
recognition and images worked and so you
know just to simplify basically playing
these neural networks backwards makes
them hallucinate and create these you
know you know beautiful or grotesque
depending on your taste images and one
effect so this was called deep dream or
Inception so one of the effects that
this new aesthetic had was a lot of
artists working with code or or media
artists started getting interesting in
the potential of machine learning in AI
and I was at a an event at Dark Matter
in Brooklyn and I saw an artist named
Kyle McDonald who's presenting some of
his recent work and he had all these
clusterings of you know words clustered
by similarity or scales or images and
they all were clustered in this
interesting way and then the last one
was this giant you know point cloud and
as he dragged his mouse through it I
realized every point was a sample
organized by similarity you know that's
it that's what I need so I said what's
this called what do you call that
algorithm
and he said tease me so tease me stands
for t distributed stochastic neighbor
embedding the T - actually stands for
tea - distributed so you know it's a
revolutionary algorithm and a
revolutionary acronym and basically what
this does is it's dimensionality
reduction algorithm but in simplest
terms it puts things similar things
close together and doesn't care about
things that are different so these are
images it's a low resolution image and
so I took some samples and I ran a tease
me on it so here the blue points are
high hats the red or snare and the green
are kick drums so this is the algorithm
in action
every little dot finds this place so it
worked so now I had to live code it so I
took 3,000 samples and I put everything
I put you know marimbas and vibra phones
and trumpets as well as all my
percussion samples and I started live
coding traversals through it and sounded
like this
and I really I memorized this geography
I knew where marimba island was I knew
where on the percussion continent to
find a darbuka or the djembe but after
working on it for about two years I
figured out there was a better way to do
it and that was that if I took out all
the kind of tonal samples the marimba is
and the vibra phones and the trumpets
and just had more dry percussion sounds
what it was actually doing was
organizing it you know from the lowest
kick to the highest pitched hi-hat you
know and it's just that the tease me
tries to conserve space so it was
crushing it into some sort of weird
curve and so what that meant see in a
second basically you could draw a curve
through it there we go so you draw a
curve through the distribution and I
tried all sorts of ways of curve fitting
algorithms but it just always was better
if I did it by hand and then you could
unwrap it and then assign it to a grid
and now there's two meaningful
dimensions so along this way it's the
drums are getting from low pitch to high
pitched and then on this axis it's
variations within the same sort of
frequency energy and so then I didn't
have to memorize anymore
I knew we're just numerically where the
drums were and so the live I got
commissioned again by the wave er to
turn the live coding tease me into a VR
experience and I'll just show you a
little some early sketches so
you're sitting on a you're on a giant
laptop and you're watching the TC being
formed and then you see me code a little
bit but then what's interesting is that
the users get to enter and this is a
three dimensional TC of samples and make
their own rhythm
[Music]
[Music]
so I started to think what other musical
structures what the teasing you would do
to different kinds of musical structures
so this is all the diatonic seventh
chords and every key and I was very
proud of the tease me because cords find
their friends and it makes a circle and
so it's a sort of a circle of fifths and
if you unwrap it again you get two
dimensions one where it's variations on
the same chord and then on the x-axis
whenever you move over one one note is
different if you move over to two notes
are different and you're always moving
towards the next key in the circle of
fifths so now I can create progressions
without knowing what chords I'm playing
just by how far I want them to change
harmonically
[Music]
so then this is a tease me of synth
presets interpolating between the
nearest seven to the mouse and the
reason that they're so three points is
because when you make a tea something
you want to have ideally a lot of points
and I'm using the presets to compare is
that every city commercially synth
commercially available since that I've
been able to find has modal parameters
where they're switches or switching the
two waveform or modes and you just can't
interpolate or you get all sorts of
clips so these I curated these because
they all have their modal switches at
the same place so if you know a synth
that is fully parametric please come
talk to me after the talk and this is a
tease me working on every possible
rhythm with eight beats and again the
teasing surprised me with the topology
it found because it basically made this
sort of fractal grid so that all I had
to do was rotate it and then assign it
to kind of clean it up and then again it
has the property where if I move over by
one the beat is different by one beat
and if you move over by two it's
different by two I couldn't find any
meaning in the axes
but it is an interesting way to explore
rhythms then I got a little distracted
from music this is a TC grid of my
former collaborator from circus days
b-boy wd-40 this is every frame in a 15
second clip and I'm time to show you
right now
but I've done some experiments where if
you move through this at the fast speed
put like kind of triangle waves through
it you can get him to do all sorts of
choreographies that that he never did
that's interesting then I took this
image of a flower and I did a TC of all
the pixels and the background is just
blue to make it pop so this is the tease
me unwrapping the pixels
and it kills me every time that it tears
here I just feel like good but that's
that the tease me is optimizing for
things that are nearby being similar so
sometimes groups get broken up then I
think I went too far because I did a
tease me of the images in the sequence
of the tease me of the pixels of the
image of the flower and by this point
people were just like messaging me like
you okay man
you're sure are tweeting a lot about T
sneeze and and like truth be told like I
was literally dreaming about T sneeze at
night so I started to think what it what
else can this new this kind of new
revival and AI and machine learning
bring to to musical creativity so when
deep dream first was released I was
really fascinated by the way it could
take content and super by a super impose
new content and this sort of
hallucinatory like eidetic way that it
it knows about the shape of the tree and
it fills it in and I was like I talked
to some people working in the field I
said can we do this for sound you know
I'd love to take the sound of a babbling
brook and turn it into distant djembe
A's or something and they were like nope
this algorithm won't work on sound
because this algorithm only understands
spatial relationships and it can't make
sense of time but only took one more
year till the same group at deep mind
created wavenet and so the real
breakthrough of wavenet is speech
synthesis it's kind of the best and most
natural speech synthesis we have yet and
this just came out in 2016 but of course
I wasn't interested in speech synthesis
I want to hear some weird noises lucky
for me
the lovely folks at Google magenta which
is a group at Google devoted to finding
how AI and machine learning can benefit
artists and creativity they felt the
same so they trained wavenet on 400,000
individuals audio samples of instruments
playing one note and you can see here
this ridiculous encoding this is the
original spectrogram and then like know
what did you there's you know 10 to 15
features and with that they can
reproduce the original waveform so
they're it's happening on a waveform
basis and there's some crunchy sort of
artifacts that turn up which of course I
love I don't know what's going on with a
flugelhorn but but what was really cool
is that you could say I want something
that's 20% bass 30% glockenspiel and 50%
flugelhorn and it's not cross fading
those sounds by amplitude its generating
what it thinks the mix of those would be
sample per sample and so they released a
max for live plugin for Ableton Live and
they basically you get you can pick
different grids and you have four
instruments and you can interpolate
between them and the in the middle of
these instruments you get to these weird
places where it's kind of not in tune
because the tuning of a violin for a
certain note is not the same as a tuning
for say a saxophone so you can get these
very strange harmonics and crunchy
things and so I'm going to perform that
for you tonight so I think this is a
fairly good intro to my work no I want
to spend the next hour going deep into
the philosophical implications no I'm
just kidding
I'm gonna do a little setup where I
switch the projectors and then I'm gonna
perform for you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks Jason thanks Ron
that was amazing
so we're gonna chat although I'm still
sort of coming down from that Thanks
yeah no it's good it's just kind of I
was I don't know if you guys had the
same experience but I was sort of
wondering like do I look at the code do
I look at the screen don't like you know
it's like because they were both very
interesting so I wanted to have the code
overlaid oh yeah on the screen
yep but I couldn't find the text you're
a vim guy okay well we won't get into
like editor wars right now because
that's a hope I'm using Jim keybindings
yeah yeah vim keybindings so so we're
good yeah okay so yeah don't start that
up don't start the editor work so boy
but actually but I have to say it was it
was cool seeing I thought it worked okay
because it was you know code on top of
art might be a might be a little a
little kind of too much you know it's
pretty easy just to add a curiosity what
did oh yeah Oh turn the mic Oh turn your
mic up so out of the audience who who
spent more time looking at the code or
or the look at the code a lot okay and
then who looked at the at the around
screen okay
15:50 it's pretty cool right so then
that was the right thing to do I think
that's right yeah but then you get like
the Indigo that yeah are the box
thinking so there's a there's a time we
can talk about I could spend a while
just asking you about details of the
code and what you were doing but I'm
gonna resist doing that huh
I also do sort of live coding of a
different sort which is in my class I
actually couldn't of the class and
that's got its own set of terrors
associated with it yes you know because
it's all MIT students so as soon as you
type one wrong character they're just
like hey that's that you don't need to
do that
I was pretty low typo right today right
yeah that was good at the end I was like
I will ask you some sort of broader
questions about that do you
I'm sort of wondering what's going on in
your head as as you're essentially
constructing this piece you know and it
starts it's you know it starts nice and
easy right but there's not a lot of code
on the screen there's you know you get
the metronome set up and you get your
your first basic set of beats going but
then you know you're building up more
and more and so I'm wondering what's
going on through your head as that's
happening and also does it ever get
overwhelming like do you ever forget
like where did I put that code or or is
it all fairly clear in your mind how
it's all are kind of architected and
what it's doing
um well because I'm improvising like
sometimes I'll get to a point like today
I got to a point where I went I wanted
to stop the drums and then immediately
take out the law the root note of the
chords and I did it and then I went I
said oh this time I put the chords at
the top and they're not beside this this
um so all those little chunks of code
are called temporal recursions it's just
schedules itself to be called in the
future at a certain time so each one is
sort of a self-contained unit
um not everything there's some like
one-off commands like I'm sending I'm
sending messages to this computer on how
to control the visuals right but mostly
yeah I've set up a temporal recursion
you give it a name and then you tell it
to call itself back in the future and
then the ways you can create rhythms are
you put conditionals in there
I'm only play on these beats or the way
I get the really interesting stuff is
I'm actually
changing the how soon to call itself
back in the future so it calls itself
and then it decides oh and next I'm
gonna call myself an eighth-note or
maybe a triplet and that's where you get
the more interesting right sort of
things and so you can sort of get these
sir dynamically forming Polly rhythms
yeah and then the most interesting thing
which I didn't get to do is where you
can have one call a different function
instead and that function might call it
back and so there's sort of feeding off
each other and passing each other
parameters but I kept it pretty right
some contained for now yeah I also
noticed so use you probably noticed but
you're using random here and there
yes but sparingly yeah which I thought
was kind of cool you know you can you
can you can get quickly carried away
probably with randomness but it's nice
to see well so I actually don't like
randomness I try and avoid it but the
one place where I really like it is in
in the parameters of the oscillators and
specifically the frequencies mm-hmm so
I'll say the frequency of this is it
takes two beats for this wave right play
but one out of three times it's it takes
three beats for it to play and that
that's where I find the random really
interesting and then the other and then
maybe I'll use it in the amplitude of
the wave just give it to so it's
sometimes it's playing nearby and then
sometimes it'll go a bit further but I
don't I don't like just random right
it's another it's another style yeah
interesting the so so if you're and I
don't I don't do much improvising myself
as an instrumentalist but you know but
but I imagine when you are improvising
you know there's a lot going in your
head but it's it's probably not
necessarily just the individual note you
know like John Coltrane is not thinking
like c-sharp D
that's natural right he's sort of he's
thinking larger shapes yes and forms as
this is always happening and of course
you know generally you're conforming to
to a prettier tune you're you're playing
with a certain set of card changes but
I'm wondering with this it's it all
seems very detailed you know and and do
you where do you think you are sort of
on this on this arc not good not coal
train yet but you know on this arc or
where initially you know this is a new
instrument right right and so yeah you
start off and you're just doing scales
and you're practicing the individual
notes and you're getting accustomed to
your instrument and learning how it
works and then over time you are able to
start thinking in larger larger scale
structures right and I'm wondering if
there's an analog between sort of that
you know learning and development of and
cultivating of yourself as a musician in
the sort of the traditional traditional
way versus the system that you're
working with here yeah so there is but
the problem is I'm also a coder so I'll
practice with a system and start getting
somewhere and then I'll think oh maybe
if I just change this and then I'll
totally change the system and I would
say almost 100% every show is not the
same system as the last show so you
can't
so anyway sorry and when you say the
system you you don't mean like the
particular code you're typing now you
mean the underlying yeah so engine so to
speak right so you can see like there's
some functions I call right so that's
changing and so it's temporary which is
the language I'm using is like a
bilingual language so I'm writing scheme
here but some of the functions I'm
calling are in what's called xt lang and
this is like a low-level language like C
but still written like Lisp and so I've
built this whole system for you give it
an XY point and a nearest number of
nearest neighbors and it'll it'll find
those nearest neighbors in the in the
grid yeah and then based on how far away
they are
kind of share the amplitude and the
panning and all that is written in this
lower level and I'm constantly changing
that too so the semantics are changing
the function is changing and I keep
saying I want to you know stop and then
just practice with it but it never
happens so there's that but also to your
point about you know Coltrane's not
thinking of what the specific note is I
don't know if it was him who said they
asked him is his advice for young
musicians and he said you know learn
your scales and then forget all that
[ __ ] and so like I said there's the
kind of like declarative like play this
note now play this drum now put and I'm
one I'm at least one step above that
yeah where I'm shaping waves using kind
of a platoon of frequency modulation to
create these complex waves and then
sampling from them rhythmically to pick
notes from scales yeah and then that
really seems like this this pretty nice
ingenuity of and we I think what we saw
here initially is the grid it's that
you're unrolled technique that's the
integral treason either then it rolls
back up and then it goes to the three
dimensions right yeah but in terms of of
how you organize your samples it is
that's essentially a final always I'm
always giving numbers to the grid
regardless of what it's showing right
yeah but but sort of but in terms of
just like you're saying you don't really
choose a note anymore you know yeah well
you're sort of that you you are thinking
one level higher no because you you
essentially have this sort of spatial
organization of sound yeah and now
you're thinking of traversing through
that as opposed to saying I want this
one particular hi-hat yeah and there's
even more than that because I can't even
say I want this particular hi-hat
because there was one drum that I really
wanted to play because it goes like it's
really cool and it's at position X 14 y
0 but every time it's player's positions
work well it's memorable yeah right I
will always remember that remember
forever but what else I'm doing
so I'm creating these chord progressions
by putting the sine waves through that
grid of chords
yeah but when every one of those drum
samples is tagged with the approximate
pitch and when I play a chord only drums
that are tagged with one of those four
pitches are are gonna be chosen from the
algorithm that finds the you know and
nearest neighbors so if I put in 14-0
like I did at the end and I was like oh
come on it's got to hit the chord where
it plays that sound but it didn't so I
can't choose the exact sound it's almost
like a limitation of the system that
you've built yourself yeah in order to
be able to achieve higher level so when
I play with May with scorpion Mouse
sometimes we're jamming cheese like can
you change that third chord like I don't
like the way the DOM and it goes to the
three and I'm like can you tell me when
the third quarter like I'm like no no so
I don't have that and I'm too high level
that when I work with you know human
musicians if there's a definitely a
language barrier where I'm trying to
figure out like what do they expect yeah
or how could I do that yeah but it's
also a really good challenge that helps
me grow is trying to work with musicians
yeah as opposed to say you write me or
or like like so I've been to a bunch of
live coding conferences and they'll have
like on saw live coding ensembles yeah
like holy Wow yeah you cannot I don't
even think they know what sound they're
making right cuz everyone can make every
sound oh it just all blends together
into this wild then I mean everyone has
access to oscillators and samples like
noise and filters and they're all typing
away yeah so I let any questions I
thought I'd open up the questions of the
audience and let's see there's um
there's a microphone going around oh
cool okay so speaking of the mic so we
can get that question recorded but yet
go ahead hear what happens when you get
an error on your code does it just not
play that part or
yeah I did I did miss a parameter and so
when it so because it's a dynamic
language when it goes to call itself in
the future and the new version has an
error it just doesn't play it and I get
an error in the console yeah there's
another version so that's amusing the
dynamic scheme language you can also do
all this with the low-level language and
if you make an error there it doesn't
replace the function if it doesn't
compile it won't do it
so in a way that's better but then you
have to program with types and I just
can't I just can't do it slows me down
yeah and with this being interpreted it
doesn't know that there is a bug in it
until it action no sex until it executes
it and then it stopped yeah okay yes
over here yes I just wait for the mic
yet thank you
so we in an ensemble situation and some
of the music that you're performing
today so rhythmically he's you know it's
kind of the basis for it so what do you
synchronize clock with other people or
work it I less separately if you're
playing with a drummer I don't know if
you do that but if you're playing with a
with a live percussionist kind of what's
your concept on the rhythmic framework I
try to avoid playing with live drummers
it's happened but it just is never gonna
it's never gonna work because I can't I
can't I can't groove with them you know
if you tell me exactly like you want the
snare a 32nd note late I can do that
easily but you know natural drummers
have like a group the way they speed up
and slow down and they move it the whole
band and so basically it's like they
have to like drum to a click except it's
not a click it's my really strange
rhythms and I just think frequency wise
there's too much overlap so I owe so and
then for the when you when I work with
other live coders yeah synchronize
clock synchronize clock sometimes it's a
problem because there's a lot of really
popular live coding languages like title
and supercollider
and Chuck and that's why I'm missing
sonic PI and these ones often will work
with each other but I'm kind of like a
lone wolf here extemporary I mean
there's some other users around the
world but mainly it's the the creator
and his collaborators in Australia so
sometimes it is a bit tough and I'll
just send OSC messages saying like hey
keep up to this time you should be here
yeah how about over here just kind of
working your way back um that the VRT
zni things Baron say should was that
being live coded as well um ha or is it
something like could you the kind so I
actually I don't know what I was
thinking I'm bad at faking things I
always wanted to actually be generative
and interactive so I built a system in
unity whereby whenever I was live coding
I was live coding the system in unity
and I was procedurally creating
animation events so that it captured my
performance and actually replay it oh
and it would also send the code that I
had typed and then type it in unity so
it's absolutely no one
people who saw her just like that's a
video right our friend Adam oh yeah yeah
yeah but it was real real whatever that
means let's see let's go over here
I thanks a lot I'm really interested in
new kinds of live performance and I'm
wondering what you think the vibe of
algo rave can do or what's a new kind of
experience that could come out of this
kind of live music performance well
traditionally like back in 2012 the way
people danced there was like an
algorithmic a bunch of geeks get beer in
one hand and you're reading the code and
kind of going like this and so you know
it's that's pretty boring but now so
we've been doing these shows in New York
and and all kind of lifting our chops
levels up and posting and all sorts of
weird lists and now we get all these
sort of like tech-savvy raver kids we
don't know where they came from or how
they found us but they just dance they
love this weird kind of alien music and
the vibe is really good and we're gonna
tomorrow I'm missing our algorithmic
I beam in New York and on April 20th
we're gonna play our biggest show ever
at this legendary called performance
base in New York and it's been like a
kind of a breeding ground for
experimental performance and dance since
the 80s and they just made this new
venue and they reached out to us and
they're like we want to try an algorithm
and we're like do you even know what it
is are you sure
but they have to 14k projectors and 7-7
K projectors so you are gonna be blinded
by code at this
and it's it's in collaboration with a
group called baby castles that do indie
video games so there's going to be
arcades everywhere there's going to be
people wearing arcades coming on the
dance floor and you could actually play
the arcade on them so I feel like this
feels like a kind of futuristic that
like hey there's a lot of geeks now and
sometimes they like to dance right yeah
who else there were some back there
let's go all the way in the back I was
wondering what your kind of relationship
with the audience's when you're
performing cuz like on the one hand like
live performance is very like you're
aware of you know your audience that
you're being watched but on the other
hand when I'm coding I tend to just zone
out what's around me so I was wondering
where you're sort of are on that
spectrum yeah for me this is the the
tragedy of live coding you know I'm I
come from background of being like a
very live and physical performer and
just being keenly aware of the audience
you know more than knowing they're
watching me just really feeling the vibe
and yeah you can't do it when you're
coding you you can barely you can barely
hear the music when you're coding really
I mean it's still going in your ears but
you're you know you're just so razor
focused on like how do I get the next
thing to happen that you're definitely
not embodied you know if I think it's
the opposite and like I said it doesn't
matter how you type the keys no one will
will feel it right you know sometimes I
hit the eval button extra hard that's
like the the one action moment in live
coding is evaluate
but but yeah so so well what my dream
was for this performance but I can't
find anyone who will leak leak one to me
I wanted to get a magic bleep so that
there's no laptop and that I'm looking
at the audience maybe and the code is
floating somewhere there so that is
that's my next step I tried it with the
hololens and i had such a headache yeah
I couldn't code for two days so I
thought it might still be a while before
yeah well you really need but but I
think that would be that would to me
seems like it could be the solution
that'd be one solution and the second is
I keep I keep getting this point where
I'm live coding looks sometimes a live
code and it'll be really algorithmic
like all sorts of like loops and
iteration and nested-if statements and
these really emergent properties and
then as I find what's cool in that I
start you know abstracting it into these
little functions and I start just using
these little functions like instruments
and then I say hey how many functions am
I really using 10 and so it makes me
wonder if there's a way to build a
system in virtual reality for instance
or mixed reality where you're coding but
you're physically moving around and yeah
like if there was a notion of taking
little chunks of code yeah you
physically locating them which might
also just help you specially think of of
the music in the space and structurally
what's going on yeah and then if it was
again magical leap then I was like it's
like I'm here the code is here and I'm
putting
get around that would be cool yeah me
five okay and then there was one
question right at the very back hi so
your um your tea a comment first your TC
and a TC reminded me of Usher so oh
thanks for that so I just started
engineering school but I'm also a
massage therapist and a musician so
something I think about often is when
I'm sort of moving my clients like
through body movements I'm usually
thinking like I wish I could hear or see
their stickiness and so because there's
because of the Kinect you were talking
about I'm wondering is is there anything
you're thinking about in healthcare
applications at all yeah I've always
wanted to build a Kinect
app that like hey you're slouching you
know like you slouched for 95 percent of
today or something and I never got
around to it I don't know if Kinect is
is the best way it's not a very precise
to that level like I think these little
tightness is are really precise but I
have I did see a new technology recently
I forgot what it's called but it looks
like a little like one of those Apple
Mouse things and it sticks on your back
right here oh you guys know what it is
and it measures the angle of your spine
and it'll like buzz you if you slouch
too much and so I want to get it I don't
know if I'll be able to stand it but I
think I think there's a lot like I
recently started using the muse headband
I mean super skeptical of EE G's but
this one it's it's pretty impressive for
the one little task it does and I sort
of was thinking about using the muses a
EEG headset kind of consumer grade very
low spatial resolution but supposedly
will tell you if you're no I wouldn't
say supposedly it definitely tells you
when your mind is active and when you
chi'lan focused and I've even tried live
coding with it so I thought maybe if I
had that and that was an input into the
chain there could be a little bit of the
users experience I don't know exactly
how that answers your question but but
I'm interested like you know as a
performer you know I think I think the
like the current state of computers is
like the less you use them the healthier
you are but unfortunately in 2018 there
is nothing you can do this useful
without a computer so I feel like it's
the computer that has to change and you
can all you can all come up and see my
keyboard later on very ergo keyboard
yeah cool let's see
Beck over there yes you so I have two
questions one is is there any situation
where you change what you described as
the system or like the underlying
functions live and then my second
question is how do you teach this or how
would how would someone go about
learning this does it require like
extensive experience improvising in
other music or music in general
wait so you say the first question what
was the first question the first
question was so you talked about how I
use oh yeah I remember lines of marriage
I try to avoid that life I do it all the
time
at home but it's definitely risky
because if you make a mistake at the low
level I don't mean like a doesn't
compile mistake I mean like it's a it's
not memory manage to low level one so
you could create a memory leak in real
time while you're coding
oh and I've also created like I've just
like done something recursive where I
call a function and I didn't realize
that that function calls a function that
sometimes calls that function and just
blow up the stack so but I think I would
like to do that I think that's like as
cool as it can get to change that
low-level stuff and I did use unity for
the visuals today because I I'm always
toying with making this into a VR
experience but extemporary actually has
full it has nano VG and opengl and even
the open source video game engine so you
can do all the visuals in it so it's a
really so them I think the most
interesting thing is where you build a
system then use the high-level language
to put some patterns into it and then
you change the system with those
patterns in it and then the second thing
was so the second thing is how do you
teach this stuff how do you teach this
stuff oh it's great fun if you're
learning on your own I would not
recommend extemporary I mostly wouldn't
recommend extemporary to anyone like no
well I mean because they so I would
never join a club they would accept me
as a member yeah no no it's it's more
like what's his name
if you're in loathing and loathing in
las vegas thunder stomps in the
beginning of his book he says i would
never recommend drugs to anyone they
just worked for me and yeah so so the
creator of extemporary he specifically
said you know there's this trend of like
easy easy to use live coding tools and
this is just saying like no this is
gonna give you all the possibility and
all the power there is and it's really
really incredible I mean he controls
robotic telescopes with it
so you're saying maybe this is like the
second thing you should learn yeah well
I mean look if you if you have a strong
engineering background like you'll
figure it out easy you know but you're
talking about jump into it easily
there's
other languages like especially sonic PI
which is Ruby and just made kind of with
musicians in mind and it's very easy you
don't it doesn't matter if you have a
background in improvisation and then
there's other ones like title which is
this high school language that's all
combining these little operators to
create these emergent rhythms and that
you could just mess with the numbers and
the order of the functions and just see
what you like you know so there's
languages out there where you could
download it tonight and start making
cool beats but extemporary is more like
a full it's not a it's not a librarians
top of a language it's its own language
and then just the other answer that
question is on Thursday night Jason is
actually teaching a class about this you
know so so folks who are attending will
I think will leave the class essentially
having a basic feel for how it works and
being able to make their own life
khottabych yeah and usually what I find
when I teach I teach like the very
basics like specify what note when kind
of thing and everyone takes it in their
own direction and half of the things
people do I'm like I've never thought of
doing that so which actually is it kind
of reminds me of something I think you
said when we when we were working at
Harmonix which was like one of the best
parts of this kind of very rapid coding
is actually the the accidents and the
mistakes you know and the bugs and when
a bug turns into a feature or a bug
turns into sort of a new interesting
artistic concept that you wouldn't have
thought of otherwise and then you save
it and you know all my errors are better
than my ideas I appreciate and that
actually kind of brings me to a sort of
a high level a higher level question
than I thought maybe we you could talk
about maybe endeth because we're pretty
close to out of time but you know you've
taken us through your whole life which
was you know amazing to see actually how
it all you know started and how one
thing led to the other and this idea
triggered
you know something that happened to you
years later and I love the you know how
there's a there's an overall overarching
arc of creativity and and and you know
in design and also there's a lot of
creativity in the small with like you
know you're thinking about how to be
creative on a second to second basis is
what we just saw here but my question
really is what happens when you get
stuck like what do you does that happen
to you do you ever have writer's block
or coders block or you know or something
like that and if so how do you get past
it and what is sort of what is your
creative process for coming up with new
ideas no my problem is the opposite like
I have too many ideas it never it just
never ends and so you know these days
I'm I'm sort of trying to to not be
creative and just work on execution
because you know I'll start working on
something and then I'll think of
something else and I could just you know
just keep coming up with new ideas okay
but so so alright so it's awesome you
don't have that problem some of us might
have that problem like what do I do
oh do you so what what would you what
would you say like what helps you how
did you get to the point where like you
you know you're essentially you have too
many ideas oh no I mean yeah I mean I
just can't you know like I just can't me
I get stuck in the subway and I see a
subway commercial and gives me an idea
there's no thing I just I okay write
that down and everyone subway yeah no no
no yeah you know I'm really hesitant to
give advice cuz I don't know why I have
all these ideas but one thing I can
think of I don't know if it's the was
the result the ideas or the symptom of
the way my mind works but I kind of I
kind of have never had a very normal
life like I'm constantly changing
you know I freelance I work lots of
contracts I'm always changing my you
know sleep cycle traveling and your
environment environment yeah I'm not one
to just stay look I tried I tried a
full-time job about a year ago I did one
year and I just I just couldn't do it so
yeah I don't know I don't know if that's
helpful to other people
well it just says so just to my take on
it from looking what yeah I think maybe
one way to interpret it is that you have
you have done a lot of different things
and had a lot of experiences you know
but the way I think or I guess the way I
think Jason's mind works is that he
essentially uses every every slight
little opportunity that comes his way
whether it's what he had for breakfast
or just you know a blinking sign on the
road especially blinking especially
looking signs on the road but sometimes
what you had for breakfast as a way of
you know everything is input and
everything everything is sort of is
going in and and you know changing your
environment a lot and and trying all
these different things I think I'll kind
of contribute but what I see happening
is if there's this wonderful feedback
cycle of sort of happening you know
throughout your journey where where
something happens here and then you you
know how to use it later and then that
causes something else to happen and then
you know how to use it later and I think
all those things essentially help feed
on on each other to you know to
essentially make make this happen you
know what you just made me think of
something something I did notice about
myself that I don't really see other
people doing is that I give a lot of
attention to unimportant details
unimportant details yeah attention to
unimportant details yeah like texture on
the floor or how light reflects
somewhere these kinds of things or
they're sounded as you're walking down a
hallway at a particular spot sounds a
certain way yeah
that may be that okay so will that I
think with that I think we'll have to
okay tonight thank you so much thanks so
much
[Applause]